where do people go wrong when it comes
to signing big accounts start with you
need to make sure you're prospecting
strategy is on point and you're
targeting the right customers make sure
that's backed up by data do your market
research the actual prospecting it takes
a lot longer than execution in my
opinion in terms of actually calling the
managers or emailing the longest part it
probably takes an hour and a half maybe
a day to do the actual prospecting make
sure you're targeting the right people I
would always say in terms of Target look
for companies that are growing I've got
high attrition if it's a big client I'd
say Target one a day a lot of people
make the mistake but they maybe have a
few meetings and then just give up and
move on with these big ones they took a
long time so I'd suggest like having a
meetings Target in place making sure you
go in you have to map the whole company
out find out who the key stakeholders
are the key decision makers who's the
MSP on site and then you're consulate
linking in you know do we already know
anyone with this company I'm not
building maybe a network of candidates
that have left there and getting some
information and intelligence as well